how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
last night we got the official trailer
for moon night and i have to say i do
believe moon knight is going to be one
of my favorite disney plush shows that
is coming from marvel it looks awesome
and judging by the comments on my
reaction video it seems like everybody
pretty much thinks the same thing but
for those people who don't know exactly
who moon knight is the trailer can be a
little confusing so we're gonna break it
all down today and of course if you love
marvel and you want to stay up to date
on moon knight and the mcu be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos now the first thing that
you need to know about this trailer is
you really need to know who moon knight
and mark spector are if you don't have
somewhat of a general basis of who they
are this trailer might be pretty
confusing but don't worry i got you
covered moon knight originally appeared
in not his own comic but werewolf by
knights comic he debuted in 1975's
werewolf by night number 32 and number
33. werewolf by night aka jack russell
found himself being hunted by a
mysterious hooded white figure who said
that he could call him moon knight now
originally moon knight wasn't introduced
as a hero but he wasn't exactly a full
villain now moon knight wasn't really
meant to be a main character they
brought him in werewolf by night as a
side character but since people really
liked him they brought him back over
time and eventually gave him his own
comic run and this is actually
interesting because in this one scene
where we see moon knight in his full
costume beating the crap out of somebody
this is actually werewolf by night that
he's beating up coincidentally marvel
studios is doing a werewolf by night
halloween special later on this year so
they are going to connect now in the
original story mark spector aka moon
knight is a mercenary and he's hired by
a group of bad guys simply known as the
committee to capture werewolf by night
but he eventually gets a conscious and
he eventually lets werewolf by night go
and the two of them fight their way out
however in the 80s when moon knight
would get his own comic run they
actually retconned his origin and
changed it moon knight was still mark
spector and he was still a mercenary
andy was working in sedan with his
friend frenchie they were working for
somebody called bushmen bushmen ended up
killing an archaeologist in which moon
knight ended up saving that
archaeologist's daughter marlene
buschmann continued to kill people until
mark spector eventually stood up to him
however he lost the fight and bushman
left him there in the desert for dead he
did manage to crawl his way back to
marlene right before he actually died
but when he died the statue of konchu
the god of the moon and vengeance
brought him back to life he took the
statue's robe and then became moon
knight now from here in the comics mark
spector actually gains multiple
personalities and in the comics and in
the trailer he suffers from dissociative
identity disorder and he has multiple
personalities that he sometimes really
doesn't have any control over and when
he switches from one personality to the
other the one that he switches to has no
idea what the other just did this
started when mark spector became moon
knight he created other personalities
and sort of other characters to help him
fight crime and we do actually see this
in the trailer we can see him having
different names throughout the trailer
we hear him being called steven but at
one point in time he picks up a phone
which is very old because it's a flip
phone but when he picks up the phone it
says that this person's name on the
other side is layla which could be his
romantic interest and could simply be
marlene from the comics just renamed but
she calls him mark and he says why did
you call me mark this is because he is
no longer in the mark specter identity
so he has no idea what happened as mark
he is actually stephen grant in this
scene and steven grant is one identity
of mark who is actually very rich and is
a wall street player he's a millionaire
who is extremely well dressed and goes
to fundraisers and galas much like bruce
wayne he then has the jake lockley
identity jake is a cab driver who goes
around gathering intel and he's pretty
brutal he's got eyes and ears everywhere
and he's very dark very rude and he kind
of just beats people up so we have mark
spector jake lockley steven grant who i
believe they're kind of combining into
one character here because we can see
that steven is kind of rough around the
edges it looks like he is somewhat of a
cab driver in this trailer perhaps
steven is just going to be one
personality of jake and steven and we
can see him turn into this rough guy
perhaps into a millionaire in the show
so mark spector the mercenary the xcia
member with a character that is somewhat
the combination of stephen grant and
jake lockley then of course we have moon
knight but then we have konshu now as it
turns out in the comics konshu isn't
exactly the moon god he's actually what
is called an elder god and he's actually
banished from the earth realm but he
uses mark spector to do his bidding as
moon knight so when mark spector takes
on the personality of konchu he's either
an alternate personality or he's the
actual real elder god living inside of
mark's mind and he communicates with him
psychically and sometimes he gives him
advice like a parent would but sometimes
he actually uses mark to do his own
bidding as a bloodthirsty and vengeful
elder god and this is actually who we
see here in this hallway scene walking
towards mark or i should say stephen in
the scene where he's absolutely
terrified and doesn't know if he's
actually seen this god in the hallway
because what's happening here is he
can't really differentiate between his
personalities and he's kind of starting
to lose control over everything his
personalities are becoming too much we
can actually see in one scene he kind of
wakes up and all of a sudden realizes
that he has a gun in his hand this is
because he is switching from one
personality to the other and he doesn't
remember anything about what just
happened when he was the other person
they all have their each individual own
lives they are all actually really
separate people in his own mind because
he can't differentiate between them so
throughout this trailer he really
doesn't know if he's kind of going crazy
or if this is all actually happening to
him so now that you know about his
disassociative identity disorder the
trailer should probably make a little
bit more sense now and we can also see a
few scenes which do seem to show us kind
of an origin story of mark spector
because we see him in what looks to be
some old ancient egyptian ruins and he
seems to be in some sort of a temple
this could be when it's just mark
spector as a mercenary when he's working
for bushmen and actually becomes moon
knight because obviously if they're
going to tell an origin story of moon
knight they're going to have to show the
whole ordeal with konshu especially
since they do show him in this trailer
now ethan hawk is playing the villain in
moon knight and not really much is known
about his character yet there was some
sort of a rumor going around that he
could be playing randall specter who was
the brother of mark spector who goes by
shadow knight however this is in no way
confirmed and is just speculation at
this point but in one point in time in
the comics randall spector tries to kill
himself he commits a lot of crimes in
the comics including at one point in
time killing mark spector's old
girlfriend but he has stopped from
killing himself and he is convinced that
he is actually the new avatar for konshu
the elder god so he starts killing
people again so his brother moon knight
will find him he does this so that he
could try to kill him but he also could
be playing amin ra the sun god who in
the comics is actually the father of
konchu so he could be playing that
avatar because the two of them do fight
with each other in the comics this
trailer doesn't tell us too much about
the actual storyline it is still
somewhat of a teaser trailer its focus
really is just kind of giving us a first
look at moon knight and all of the
characters that are going to be involved
and really throughout this trailer what
you can really take away is how messy
his life is between all of his different
personalities and this happens in the
comics too to the point to where he
doesn't even know if he is sort of a
vessel for konchu or whether he just
went crazy and imagined everything but
one thing that differentiates moon
knight from a lot of other different
comics and superheroes is that although
he is kind of crazy he is actually very
very real in fact he teams up with
spider-man a lot and he throws around
the f-word more than i think almost any
other character does in the comics and
as you can see from this trailer it's
going to be very dark it's going to be
very gritty and i think it's going to be
one of the best disney plush shows and
just one of the best projects coming
from marvel but let me know what you
think about it in the comments down
below and i hope this breakdown helped
you understand further what is happening
in this trailer be sure to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest moon knight and
mcu videos for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you